Alright, what do you think, Charles?
>> Okay, so I think a couple of things. Let me
just talk this out loud. So we're trying to learn incrementally.
We're trying to figure out, how if we just kind of
keep adding these random variables in a sort of way to
what you described before what we would end up at. So
why do we want to choose alpha t with a particular
kind of property well if you look at it, it's clear
that alpha t at each time step is moving closer and closer
to zero. So it means you start out learning a
lot and you sort of believe things less and less and
less or you let things change you less and less and
less over time. So what is that likely to end up
at? Well the first thing I notice that well if
it's going to do that then it has to converge. Some
point. It just makes sense. So I, that helps me to
eliminate the second answer. But actually, that also let's me eliminate
the fourth answer because in some ways they, that says the same thing.
So that leaves us with the expected value of x and the expected value
of x squared. For the expected value of x squared. Whichever one it is
that is variance. Okay so, I'm going to go with, the expected value of x.
>> So, the expected value of x, right. So, so it turns out that this
is actually a wave computing the average
by just, you know, repeatedly sampling and updating
your values. And, and the way to think about it,
is that sometimes the x values that we draw are going
to be a bit above the average, and it's going to
pull the v value up. Sometimes it's a little bit below
the average, and it's going to pull the value down.
But in the limit, all those pulls and pushes are going
to cancel out, and it's going to settle in on the
actual average value or the expected value of this random variable.
>> Right, because in principle, you're going
to see an infinite number of those things.
And effectively all you are doing is adding them all up, and sort
of, you know. Well you're effectively averaging them one little bit at a time.
>> Yeah, that's a good thing about it, that
in fact it's adding them up and it's computing
a weighted average, but the weights are these alpha's
and the weights are decaying over time so we're
going to put more weight on the more recent
ones, but some more weight on the further away
ones but it sort of doesn't matter because the
order, since we're drawing this iid, the order doesn't
matter and the thing that has to converge to is the mean.
>> Right. I like it.
>> So let's relate that back to what we do in Q-learning.